how would you describe this moment in
your life I'd have to say it's the
happiest time in my life
Kim Richards getting emotional at the
premiere of marriage boot camp reality
stars I feel our relationship isn't
going anywhere
she and her secret boyfriend of six
years wind cats star on the new season
this is a relationship we didn't really
know anything about how did you keep it
so secret for so long
um well I guess we just kind of do our
own thing even oh we just managed to
keep it kind of private and now you're
making it very public and putting it out
there on TV why was marriage Boop
something you wanted to do with Winn
we really wanted to see where it went I
mean I think we were kind of stuck in
stagnant and I felt like doing marriage
boot camp would push us along and we
were stuck in a few areas and I thought
that maybe this would be the final you
know there was just there's a lot of
areas that we weren't really moving
forward in and so I thought that this
would be this would be it you know why
it was this a relationship worth
fighting for
I loved win and when loves me and it
wasn't something I was willing to give
up on so
we're fighting for you know our kids
love each other we love each other but
we really weren't moving forward in a
lot of areas so where do things stand
today with you and when are we in a
relationship I guess you'll have to wait
and find out marriage boot camp marks a
return to reality TV for Kim who stepped
away from The Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills after season 7 you know what Kim
you just want to be on a show and I'm
your meal ticket I mean honey I didn't
want to be here kind of I'm sorry this
is the kind of stuff I'm your meal
ticket I'm happy to be away from it I
really when my grandson was born I just
want to step away from the negativity
and focus on my my children my grandson
and you know we're free of problems and
people that weren't positive today Kim
is focused on staying sober I really
love how I feel but it's also you know
my children my grandson I want it and I
want to be here forever I'm here for as
long as I can be to be a part of my
children's lives my grandson my
grandchildren and in myself you know I'm
loving life so yeah putting Kim first
yeah and on her family I'm good with
both my sisters today I mean I have a
great relationship with both of them
family is important and I just don't
think there's there's a reason for
anybody or anything to get in a way of
it so we're all good it seemed like all
these little pieces in your life have
fallen together seems like your favorite
role yet is grandma how would you
describe this moment in your life I'd
have to say it's the happiest time in my
life you make me cry but being a
grandmother has definitely brought up
the best part
again I just feel like there's nothing
like it please to change my life
have you put any pressure on for more
grandbabies you know I tried not to he's
really what first there wasn't any need
to because Huxley really has been such a
joy and gift us there really wasn't a
need to but now they're taking little
trips alone two of them and so I did
throw out oh wow guys Napa how magical I
wonder if something magical can happen
she was like Bob I'm sorry like this is
the first time I mentioned it but I am
kind of hoping that soon there'll be
another little boy or maybe a little
girl you know yeah I'm definitely
starting that it did mention it recently
but it's just creeping in it's
definitely yes I would love for them to
have another one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]